haywood stays with it on the offensive
class
gets some room baseline and gets two
gordon with a little burst
haywood tatum
doubled leans in anyway
that's so celtics really struggled in
that miami game
versus the zone about three three
seconds to shoot
emphatic two eight on the shot clock
[Applause]
which in this case is the game clock
however
makes the move kicks it to the corner
hayward's gonna go back to tatum tatum
will take it this time knock it down
that's sweet basketball
got ties with him i've got lucky there
gordon hayward good cut by gordon
hayward memphis and washington
the way that brad's describing it is he
wants these guys to get ready as tatum
goes hard to the basket
and just explodes on the rim like he was
going to go into a dribble handoff
and he said wait a minute i can turn the
corner on this play
that easy bucket
he's passing up the shot double team on
tatum pays off
up for two and a good block hayward
jumping back into the play
i mean he really covers some ground late
get that out of here
heywood they find brown for a three
short
rebound kept alive tatum steps back
beyond the line
buries it good tip out by i think that
was kim
and then on the other end paul goes back
to tatum look at the fadeaway
big-time clutch shot look at the counter
i mean no hand in his face whatsoever
[Applause]
take him again pull up goddess
just put this game on his shoulders